vamos a usar la ecuación que acabamos de
inferir para resolver el problema que
definimos en el vídeo anterior así que
escribamos de nuevo el problema la
diferencia en distancia es igual a menos
500 metros recordamos que la distancia
hacia abajo es negativa de acuerdo a
nuestra convención y aquí nuestro
precipicio está hacia abajo precipicio
hacia abajo
tenemos una moneda que la lanza vamos
hacia arriba es decir tiene una
velocidad positiva y esta es una
velocidad inicial de 30 metros por
segundo y es positiva porque la
dirección de esta velocidad es hacia
arriba quedamos que la aceleración es
igual a la fuerza de gravedad que es
igual a menos porque va hacia abajo 10
metros sobre segundo al cuadrado lo
redondeamos a 10 metros por segundo al
cuadrado aunque en realidad es 9.8 y
fracción pero para facilitar los
cálculos lo redondeamos a 10 y aquí
siempre es hacia abajo
y finalmente escribimos la fórmula que
encontramos la velocidad final al
cuadrado es igual a la velocidad inicial
al cuadrado más dos veces la aceleración
por la distancia o la diferencia de la
distancia tenemos aquí que la diferencia
en distancia es igual a la velocidad
inicial por el tiempo más la aceleración
por el tiempo al cuadrado entre dos y
aquí vamos a sustituir todos los datos
que tenemos sabemos que la diferencia en
distancia es esta de aquí menos 500
menos 500 metros es igual a la velocidad
inicial que es esta 30 metros por
segundo por el tiempo por el tiempo más
la aceleración que queremos que es la
gravedad que es esto la aceleración
menos 10 metros por segundo al cuadrado
por el tiempo al cuadrado tiempo al
cuadrado entre 2
para facilitar un poco el cálculo
ahorita voy a omitir estas unidades y
voy a reescribir esta ecuación como
menos 500 igual a 30 por t más bueno de
hecho es menos porque tengo menos 10
entre 2 va a ser igual a menos 5 menos 5
de al cuadrado
si han tomado ya clases de álgebra y si
no consulten los vídeos que tenemos al
respecto ustedes sabrán cómo resolver
ecuaciones cuadráticas como ésta aunque
aquí veremos cómo resolver esta ecuación
vamos a poner todos los términos del
lado derecho de la ecuación
voy a tener 5 de cuadrada porque estoy
pasándolo de este lado es decir voy a
sumar 5 t al cuadrado en ambos lados de
esta igualdad y voy a restar 30 t en
ambos lados me va a quedar menos 30 t y
aquí tengo menos 500 todo esto va a ser
igual a 0 y podemos dividir a ambos
lados 105 para simplificar aún más las
cosas me quedaría t cuadradas menos 33 5
es igual a 6 t menos 565 me quede igual
a 100 y esto es igual a 0
resolvamos esta ecuación cuadrática para
aquellos que necesiten un recordatorio
aquí lo voy a escribir en otro color y
en esta parte las raíces de cualquier
ecuación cuadrática que en este caso
éste van a encontrarse como t es igual a
menos b más menos raíz cuadrada de b
cuadrada menos 4 a c todo esto
/ 2
donde a es el coeficiente de t cuadrada
b es el coeficiente de t y c es la
constante
ahora resolvemos sustituyamos estos
coeficientes en esta fórmula voy a
ponerlo en otro color para darle
variedad tenemos que t es igual a esto
es
esto es ve y esto se ve que es menos 6
menos por menos es más
esto es 6 más menos la raíz cuadrada
debe cuadrada menos 6 x menos 6 636
- 4 por a 1
por c se es menos 101 por menciones
menos 100 todo esto entre 2 pero
queremos que es 1 este coeficiente es 1
así que nos queda 2 simplificamos y nos
quedan 6 más
menos raíz cuadrada de menos 4 x menos
100 es igual a más 400 36 más 400 es
igual a 436 la raíz cuadrada de 436 todo
esto entre 2 esto esta raíz cuadrada es
aproximadamente igual a 20.9 entonces
estate el tiempo las raíces de esta
ecuación cuadrática se aproximan a 6 más
menos 20.9 entre 2
y déjenme hacerles una pregunta si yo
tuviera 6 - 20.9 tendría un número
negativo sería algo aproximado a menos
14.9 y aquí este es un número negativo
lo cual no tiene sentido si estamos
hablando del tiempo no podemos tener un
tiempo negativo así que la raíz que nos
va a quedar la que tiene sentido en este
contexto es con el tiempo
aproximadamente igual a 6 + 20.9 entre 2
que es aproximadamente igual a 26.9
entre 2 que a su vez esto es
aproximadamente igual a 13.45 segundos
es interesante si ustedes recuerdan hace
4 o 5 vídeos cuando vimos este problema
dejando caer la moneda simplemente
soltando la desde el acantilado en este
problema yo les di el tiempo que era de
10 segundos para llegar al suelo y así
encontramos que el precipicio tenía 500
metros de altura si ustedes están en lo
alto del edificio de 500 metros o del
acantilado dejen que hay algo pequeño
como una moneda que casi no tiene
resistencia al aire le tomara diez
segundos llegar al suelo pero si lanzan
una moneda hacia arriba como le
indicamos acá esta moneda la lanzamos
hacia arriba a 30 metros por segundo de
velocidad le va a tomar 13.45 segundos
casi 13 y medio segundos en llegar al
suelo así que le llevará más tiempo lo
que tiene sentido permítanme hacer los
dibujos aquí para comprenderlo mejor
tenemos nuestro primer caso en el
precipicio o en el edificio en el que
ustedes quieran y aquí va a ser nuestro
segundo caso igual en este precipicio
que mide lo mismo
en el primer caso teníamos este objeto
pequeño y simplemente lo soltamos y lo
dejábamos caer y llegaba hasta el suelo
recorriendo una distancia de 500 metros
y aquí en este caso el tiempo era de 10
segundos ahora en este otro caso la
moneda la lanzamos hacia arriba y
después desaceleró y cayó al precipicio
ahora la distancia que recorrió desde
que empezó a desacelerar hasta que cayó
es mayor a 500 metros y por lo tanto el
tiempo que tardó en caer es de 13.45
segundos más tiempo que en el caso
anterior si hubiera salido un número
menor aquí entonces tendríamos que
revisar las operaciones pues como podría
tomarle menos tiempo a este objeto si lo
lance hacia arriba y espero que con esto
quedan más claros estos conceptos pues
ahora tienen en su arsenal todas las
fórmulas necesarias para los problemas
de movimiento
y les en los siguientes vídeos
resolveremos varios problemas para dejar
bien claros estos conceptos y después de
expandiremos los problemas para ver cómo
resolverlos cuando se tienen varias
dimensiones y diferentes ángulos para
ello les recomiendo que refrescan sus
conocimientos de trigonometría nos vemos
después